hey guys welcome to make a bit Tomic
Shay how's it going I'm doing great i
love your intro thank you i didn't make
it but i love it too we're here today to
play teenage mutant ninja turtles
hyperstone highest on the Sega Genesis
but more importantly more importantly
we're also here to show off the Retron 5
console from hyper kin they were kind of
sistan us a sample review unit and this
is their classic well it's a console
that emulates old systems using an
Android operating system on the inside
but it lets you use real cartridges
which is really nice and one of the
great things for us makes our life
easier is that it has hdmi out all right
we're gonna jump in and I'm going to
reset the game yes I'm gonna be so on
did you just say Donatella here Leonardo
I mean sir those pecs his veins are
popping indeed steroids man hey okay
we're gonna New York City ah we got
starting the sewer I guess that makes
sense their home is probably like right
right around the corner all right yeah
the foot clans like oh hey we're here
now for anyone who doesn't remember
these Turtles games back in the day I'm
is starting on the Nintendo well I guess
starting in the arcade but really in the
home it was the Nintendo that began the
Ninja Turtles video game craze yeah the
first one was that one that was really
hard really hard side scrolling and
we're like top down like exploration
game top down exploration and then you
go underwater and try to disarm bombs
and it was impossible difficult oh my
lord all right I don't remember the plot
but yeah oh no oh no who turned out the
lights yes that's oh my god aliens
where's Ripley when you need her this
one we were talking about that I'm
always talking about Ripley
you are too immature to hang with me
always hating on teenagers what I don't
want hang with you Leatherface you have
all the toys growing up or that just
made all right so I had a bunch but I
had a really good friend whose mother
was a comic book artist what but she
also collected action figures and I kid
you not one day there my friend like
brought me up to her parents bedroom and
like open the closet and I was like
what's the big deal she spread open a
bunch of clothes and there was a door
behind the clothes no don't use secret
attic filled with every toy in action
figure you know the Ninja Turtles action
figure series i was released in that
point like inbox hanging on the hanging
on these racks and we couldn't play with
any of them and i actually was even
supposed to talk about just even knowing
that they were a thing i had tons of
these toys little known fact crocodiles
exploded yeah today i had i had probably
hundred or something of these both oh
wow i have like like baseball catcher
Rafael I had stumbles out of Chef
Michael Angelo and I love those dudes I
remember I had astronaut Raphael hell
yeah but I did have the the kraang
figure I was a big one no no it was
regular size you talking about like the
foot tall one yeah I didn't have that
one I didn't have that one that's a
little that's a little much [ __ ] that
thing is weird crane Frank is very with
why does why do you feel why does his
robot like look like a man and then he
puts himself at like the crotch of the
man I say like like why why is that a
thing he could have done anything he
didn't have to do that ROK soldiers
they're from Dimension X they are it's
true everything getting bad in this
universe nope just everything bad
everything bad is from Dimension X how
am I to I don't know if that'd be my
reaction rock steady where's beba my
butt you look delicious that's
disgusting
they really love talking about how
they're gonna eat the turtles that was
like there it's all about soup man he is
a real bad shot she was like he's blind
we're not doing so hot ourselves oh no
shell shock dude what's up man it's not
looking so good I like died when he was
already holding his button but when he
sees this next time he'll beat me but
then he just exploded sitting for
Michael Bay's new teenies Rita Ninja
Turtles film but that a thing oh yeah
you even seen the kick are you kidding
me I haven't seen anything oh man all
right Michael Bay Michael Bay he's not
gonna get is oh my god the turtles look
awful what do they look like are they
human sir so they all look slightly
different and they're like roided up and
like like weird and wide and the
proportions are strange and are we here
already is this the final level man this
is a turtles in time by the way even if
you say it is it doesn't make it true
they share a bunch of levels they're
derived are you sure yes I'm positive as
megan fox in it that she april O'Neil
she actually plays Optimus Prime in the
turtles movie oh that sounds cool megan
fox is April O'Neil wow I was totally
right about that it's only cuz I
couldn't remember Rosie Huntington's
name is that who to replace I'm God we
just killed this bastard all right stock
me is that Baxter
Baxter Stockman was the flyer or
something like that oh uh Stockman I
hate you he's easy was he'd know I know
but I just don't like him he's easy
though no I'll show you the power of
super kraang means sexy kraang I think
we moved after we were my god that is
the worst kick that is a real jerk kick
oh whatever dude I know you can't hit
him when you're doing that it's like
real life dude feel like is more to come
yeah the super shredder right there's
got to be shredding say a super Treader
a real super shredder it is look at him
flying right now I will show you the
real power of the hyper stone hahaha
what is what is he doing shooting crap
in the air like that he's instantly
paying the boat is it a that might have
been designed to take my quarters you
know throw that out there it sounds like
a clown in a box being like thrown
around oh my god you got time to do a
mutant little baby turtle the power of
the hyper some dude is it yeah huh baby
wait don't die off-screen like Cyclops
x13 you die down screen yeah amazing
here we go what's gonna happen way there
more than one hyperstone uh-oh Megan Fox
here I've been in front of the Statue of
Liberty for the entire time will say 45
minutes
capital city yeah normal size who is
really responsible for saving this city
what no we did it Pete and Tom you are
the worst reporter oh those Kojima over
that he would be konami oh man thanks
for joining us everybody that was really
fun yeah teen I was one daily fun I no
no no terrible terrible uh yeah did you
have fun I had well yeah that was really
good that was a good time what do you
play on next week that's a good question
i don't know yet if you guys have any
suggestions for all we should play next
week tweet me at pc brown on twitter or
i use the hashtag megabit i'll keep eyes
on that okay and I've got a pretty
extensive library so maybe I'll have
something you guys want to see but yeah
thanks for watching enjoy the rest of
your day come back at two p.m. to watch
Chris waters and Mary Kish what'll it be
a toejam and earl panic on funca trial
yeah yeah you love that game that I love
toejam and earl not planning on [ __ ]
town as much but not too cool it's a
really cool game and they both love it
yeah so that should be fun yeah and
chris is playing it for every game
history month which is still ongoing a
game spot may is just I don't know we're
only 12 days in you got another half
month to go so yeah go to be gamespot
com /v ghm to check out all that great
content and yeah thanks for watching
everyone see you next Monday
you